what they would say is they wanted us to
lead
because they don't want to follow russia
they don't want to follow china they do
see us as the moral authority
there and you know it's perfect example
is when trump finally
um you know when syria crossed the red
line and did chemical weapons
and trump did the first shots back and
did the missiles
the number of ambassadors that came to
me and said it's so good to see the
united states lead again
so what was it like going into the u.n
because i think you just described it
perfectly i mean it seems like the most
backwards at least the security council
stuff i know they do some i suppose they
do
some good humanitarian stuff maybe uh
you can you can comment
i don't know all right well you can
comment on that obviously but like to
just go in there and have to
and try to at least defend freedom try
to get some of these
insane votes that they're constantly
doing reversed and change some of that
stuff like
i'm guessing you were walking down the
hallway people were not like oh yay
there's nikki haley
i mean it was the u.n is not for the
faint at heart
i mean every day it felt like i was
putting on body armor and
you knew we'd have a fight you just
didn't know which country were fighting
that day
but how blessed was i to defend the
country i loved so much
and i was not going to let them
criticize us about anything i
purposely went in not knowing the do's
and don'ts of the u.n
because i wanted to kind of be able to
ask for forgiveness and
and really go in with fresh eyes but i
also knew i wanted to be very black and
white i wanted to make sure they knew
what the united states was for and what
we were against and there was no gray
area i didn't care if they liked me
but i wanted them to respect america and
i wanted them to know where we stood
obama had really created this scenario
where
they didn't know what we were for you
know and he tried to appease everybody
by criticizing the u.s
and he would just throw foreign aid out
to everyone to buy
friends i didn't want any of that i
wanted to make sure that we really put
our line down in the sand of this is
where we are if you want to join us we
will partner with you
and if you don't we're going to call you
out for it and so that's why i said we
were taking names at the u.n
they thought that was like unbelievable
that i would say something so
undiplomatic yeah
but the point was if you go around
saying death to america we're going to
take down names
but if you're our friend and ally we're
going to have your back and take down
names and protect you too and so
look it was a great experience it was
it's challenging to deal with the
chinese and and to have the russians
always trying to stir the pot
and to have everybody talk negatively
about america but i wasn't gonna stand
for it i went and take one second of it
um
because i know how great we are and i
knew what they were telling me in the
quarters of how great we were yeah so
that that's actually exactly what i
wanted to ask you so like
i would imagine that the country
secretly believe that
most of the countries like they secretly
must be like yeah if the u.s doesn't
exist in freedom
then we're all kind of screwed but then
they rarely vote that way or
publicly they say all these oh they
basically just publicly but what they
would say is
they wanted us to lead because they
don't want to follow russia they don't
want to
follow china they do see us as the moral
authority
there and you know it's perfect example
is when trump finally
um you know when syria crossed the red
line and did
chemical weapons um and trump did the
first shots back
and and did the missiles the number of
ambassadors that came to me and said
it's so good to see the united states
lead again like
they that's what they want they want us
to call
out evil they want us to do good they
want us
to show something and that's why i've
always said the united states
leadership isn't going to war sometimes
just when the leaders
just when the united states says
something countries follow
you know when we mentioned this is what
should happen they do
tend to move with us and so there's good
that we have there
but we have to continue to use that
voice and be a force for good can you
explain
you either your philosophy or trump's
philosophy or both of your philosophies
just generally on when
you should use the military because i
think a lot of people think
somehow if you if you're for the
military that means you're for war
that's the case actually the reverse
yeah i mean the key is look i'm
i'm in a military family so the last
thing i'm going to say is with my
brother was full-time military
my husband is the last thing you want
your family members to go to war
but the military's there for a reason
and
what you do want is for example you know
with biden wanting to pull out of
afghanistan well my husband served in
afghanistan
i know what was happening there we don't
need thousands of troops there but you
do need
some there for intel purposes that's
really what you want is military for
intelligence
to tell you on the ground in syria
whether they're getting ready to do a
chemical weapons attack to tell you on
the ground in afghanistan
whether there's another plot for 9 11.
so
the only thing i'll say is that biden's
foreign policy is really backwards in
the way that
look at how much has changed from the
chinese delegation comes to alaska and
humiliates our american delegation
you know putin's challenging biden to a
debate how
ridiculous is that kim is starting to
test off ballistic missiles again
and here biden's falling all over
himself to do business with iran but is
boycotting georgia
you know like these things and then all
georgia the state not georgia or the
country absolutely and all these things
amy's cutting our defense spending you
know i'll be the first one to say the
military's bloated
it's bureaucratic there's a lot that we
shouldn't be paying for
but if we don't modernize our military
china and russia are already moving iran
is already speeding up
we look so distracted right now and
making sure we modernize our military
making sure we have strategic military
on the ground in certain places to keep
us
safe and to keep bad actors from doing
more harm that's an important thing
so what do you think is behind biden and
the decisions he's making this is the
question that everyone gets asked all
the time like because i think most
people don't
really believe it's biden leading this
thing anymore that it's either
the obama machine behind it or something
that's left of the clinton machine or
something else altogether like to me it
seems like if you would have asked joe
biden 10 years ago
if he agreed or disagreed with some of
the things you just said there he
probably would have agreed where now
it's like
who knows what he believes what it feels
like to me coming
you know in the transition from obama
obama to the trump administration and
foreign policy and now where it's going
it really does feel like obama 2.0 i
mean the idea that they're already
trying to make friends with iran that
was very much something obama would do
you know the idea that they're like
starting to you know
pick fights with russia in a strong man
sense but not in real results since
that's something obama would do you know
the paris climate agreement the human
rights council all these things
these trump reversals are very much
obama's stances
and so i think that that's the approach
biden's taking he surrounded himself by
obama people whether it's
you know secretary blanken or jake
sullivan or any of those those are all
obama people that would be advising him
on what obama wants
so what can be done at the international
level like with the un
at this point like if you were there
right now which probably ain't gonna
happen but if you were there right now i
mean
this this just in the last couple days
iran got put on the
the was it the women's rights council or
something they're they're leading
council i mean how ridiculous is that
well like are these
but who makes these decisions like
there's a like someone goes into a
meeting and they're like yes yes let's
put her on on the
on the women's rights council like like
how does that even happen
it's why the united nations doesn't have
credibility it's why they struggle first
of all if i was at the united nations
right now
i would immediately call a security
council hearing and hold china
accountable for what they did to the
world with covid
i would ask what the world health
organization knew i would call out
iran for all of the violations of u.n
resolutions that they're doing and say
how can you turn around and get into an
iran deal when they're violating
multiple
resolutions you know there's a lot of
things that could be done and should be
done and instead what we've seen is the
u.n ambassador
went and basically criticized america
was there was there any speech that you
had heard in the last couple years that
was more
awful than that mortified that here i
was
defending america and here the chinese
delegation goes
and humiliates the american delegation
and the u.n
ambassador basically gave them all the
fuel to do it yeah you know i mean
you don't go in we are not a racist
country we are the least racist country
and so the idea that they would
say that is it's such a i can't even
understand
what biden or the ambassador think that
will do to help america
that doesn't that's apologizing for
america i don't think they want to help
america at this point that's what i mean
about biden i don't know what biden
believes but i think the machine that's
under him or behind him or whatever it
is like do they want to help america
it made it made me sad i mean you talked
about what is
what can the u.n do what is it good for
the reason
presidents struggle with staying in the
u.n is not because
of any great actions by the u.n we see
that all the time
i think the reason they stay is because
of the veto there are only five
countries that have a veto on the
security council
in the u.n russia china u.s u.k
who am i missing france so
if you look at those if bad things
happen if russia and china try and
get together and do something bad the
u.s can stop it
that's the reason that we're on the
security council is
we can stop bad things from happening
but they waste more than they should
ever i cut three billion dollars the
first year off of that budget and that
was just low-hanging
and the lights didn't go out the
building still existed and people see
that big building and they think they're
ambassadors in there that's all staff
yeah they've got elevator operators in
there
i would say do you know how many
vaccines you could give kids with what
you're paying these elevator operators
they doubled their staff in the last 10
years and don't they
didn't wasn't there some massive scandal
where they were like racking up
something like 100 million dollars worth
of parking tickets in new york city like
it's just crazy
so ridiculous and china is infiltrating
the entire u.n
they are trying to really i think they
now control
four different agencies within the u.n
russia controls
the cyber agency believe it or not china
almost
started controlling the intellectual
property and we were able to stop that
from happening but
i mean it's just the u.n will not be
relevant until they start talking about
the things that are uncomfortable to
talk about
the uyghur genocide that's happening in
china you know
the fact that they won't even have a
meeting about that they won't even do it
yeah
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell